donc on a annoncé aujourd'hui
avec le moi que qu'on allait
augmenter la surveillance sur le
fleuve.
Pascal Robidas.
- C'est en se présentant
par le fleuve St-Laurent, dans
la réserve Mohawk d'Akwesasne,
que la ministre de la Sécurité
publique a voulu symboliquement
lancer un message.
- On a traversé tout à l'heure
la frontière. À peine plus loin
qu'ici, on a la frntre
les eaux canadiennes et les eaux
américaines. Fait qu'on voit
très bien que ça peut être
facile d'accéder, ce qui fait
qu'il vane patrouille
nautique 24/7 ici. Fait qu'il
y a déjà des armes qui sont
saisies, des arrestations
qui se font. Fait qu'il va y'en
avoir pr encore plus.
- Considérée comme l'une
des principales routes de
contrebande d'armes à feu,
Akwesasne est utilisée par
=>Voq parqyH÷]Z
est à la fois au Canada et
aux États-Unis, en plus de
bénéficier du fleuve St-Laurent.
- Au moment où trois fusillades
ont éclaont éclaont éclaont éclx
heures à Montréal la nuit
dernière, Geneviève Guilbault
annonce un investissement de6 mq
prochaines années dans
la réserve Mohawk. L'argent
sevira à ajouter des véhicules
tout-terrain et surtoutun bateas
pour la police d'Akwesasne.
La partie québécoise du fleuve
St-Laurent sera maintenant
surveillée en tout temps.
- Ce qu'on vient dire aux gens
qui ont des mauvaises
intentions, c'est quand tout
temps, en tout lieu maintenant,
on aura ille qui
sera disponible, que ce soit
en bateau, que ce soit en
motoneige ou en quatre-roues.
- Pour le chef de police
d'Akwasasne, cet asne, cet asnei
servira également à embaucher
cinq policiers supplémentaires
pour augmenter la surveillance.
- Dès qu'on traverse la ligne,
lus des policiers,
on est des simples citoyens.
Donc, on ne peut plus intervenir
à titre de policiers. Et c'est
la même chose sur l'eau.Donc sot
les techniques d'enquête,
l'efficacité de mes policiers,
l'efficacité des équipements
que nous avons qui font ensortee
l'arrestation des gens, puis
à saisir les items à bord
de leur bateau.
- L'annonce du jour serait
un pas dans la bonne direction
selon plusieurs analystes.
- Ça reste quand même
un moyen limité au Québec,
mais ça montre une volonté
politique de combattre
des réseaux qui sont bien
établis.
- Selon l'Agence des services
frontalimbre d'armes
à feu illégales saisies a
presque doublé depuis cinq ans.
Québec espère maintenant
que ses partenaires en Ontario
et dans l'état de New York vont
augmenter la surveillance
autour de la réserve. en
refermant cette porte d'entrée,
la ministre Geneviève Guilbault
fait le pari qu'elle pourra
ralentir le trafic d'armes à feu
illégales qui se retrouvent dans
les rues de Montréal.
Ici Pascal Robidas,
Radio-Canada, dans la réserve
d'Akwesasne.